l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement pour trouver
un compromis
un accord nécessaire collecte il faut
être deux ne faut pas chercher à faire
polémique il faut chercher à être
efficace et monsieur premier ministre il
y à l'épreuve des mots il y à l'épreuve
des faits comment entendez-vous
poursuivre cette action
comment voyez-vous maintenant la suite
de décisions historiques que j'espère
mes chers collègues vous êtes tous a
salué avec moi merci à partir du jeudi
19 avril retrouvez en exclusivité et en
direct du sénat les questions au
gouvernement
pour vous répondre la parole est dans
monsieur le premier ministre les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
c'est en direct et en exclusivité sur
public sénat à partir du jeudi 19 avril
14h30